stark möchte ich heute mit dem Mann der
die Welt wieder mal beschäftigt es ist
Donald Trump ja sein Comeback
anzukündigen mit 76 Jahren dazu gehört
schubse erhielt heute Hof gestern Hof
und seine Fans waren schwer entzückt
fallen wir doch mal rein
America's come back starts right now I
am tonight
president of the United States
ja er will zurück ins Weiße Haus
Selbstbewusstsein hat der Mann medial
war das Echo jedoch eher verhalten der
New York Post war es lediglich eine
Randnotiz wer hat mit der Überschrift
Mann aus Florida macht Ankündigung
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz sagte am Rande
des G20-Gipfels in Bali ich bin nicht so
beeindruckt also damit Donald Trump
überhaupt noch einmal antreten kann muss
er ja die Vorwahl der Republikaner
gewinnen aber ist der Trump Hype
eventuell schon vorbei oder sehen es nur
die Politiker so Herr Heimann sie sitzen
ja im Deutschen Bundestag und da frage
ich mich natürlich sehen das alle so
verhalten wie Olaf Scholz die nicht so
beeindruckt sind oder gibt es da auch
echte trump-fans also ich habe noch
keine getroffen ich kann Ihnen aber
sagen ich war in Sharm el Sheikh und wir
haben uns mit den Republikanern
getroffen eigentlich wegen Klimaschutz
aber man sieht schon auch das große
Thema und republikanische Abgeordnete
sagten naja er hätte
bevor Präsident geworden wäre hätte er
Themen der Menschen angesprochen hätte
deswegen auch gewonnen jetzt ginge es
nur noch um ihn selber auch der
Ausschnitt den wir gesehen haben es geht
ja immer darum dass ihm angeblich die
Wahl betrügerisch entzogen werden soll
und er jetzt wieder da Stimme und so
weiter und das würde ihnen so viel
Sympatien Kosten und deswegen hätten die
Republikaner
man kann glaube ich schon sagen die mit
terms verloren wir wissen das ja noch
nicht genau wie das im
Repräsentantenhaus ausgeht aber das fand
ich schon eine sehr interessante Analyse
und das war jetzt auch nicht mal so
irgendwie nebenbei gesagt oder das war
ja eine Sitzung bei der wir uns über die
Situation der Mitte Rechtsparteien wie
man das so schön im englischen sagt
man da aussieht ich glaube nicht dass er
gewinnt sie kennen sich ja gut aus wie
man Marketing macht auf Youtube ja auch
sehr erfolgreich wie hat es denn
überhaupt Donald Trump geschafft als
Multimillionär der gerne in seinen
goldenen Protz Bauten mit seiner Frau
gepostet hat dafür zu stehen für die
Sorgen und Nöte der Menschen als ja fast
marketing-stück worüber man schreiben
müsste oder ja es ist Marketing Chemie
das ist ja Trumps herausragende
Fähigkeit also er hat das ja ja ich
glaube er hat das gut hinbekommen
Hillary so als Feindbild aufzubauen und
ja das war natürlich genial obwohl er
eigentlich ja nicht wirklich für das
stand unbedingt was er versprochen hat
hat man eben das trotzdem abgenommen ob
es jetzt noch mal funktioniert
würde ich auch bezweifeln ich würde
jetzt nicht viel Geld auf ihn setzen
aber ich kann mich noch sehr gut dran
erinnern vor der aber sie würden auf ihn
setzen also wenn sie jetzt setzen müssen
wäre es für Trump gut dann müsste ich
erstmal den Gegenkandidaten gegen beiden
ja ich glaube das ist relativ fifty
fifty aber ich kann mich noch gut daran
erinnern gewählt werden innerhalb aber
damals war auch ist es auch immer ja in
der Partei das schafft er niemals das
heißt es jetzt auch wieder es wird
sicherlich schwierig aber ich kann mich
noch genau daran erinnern das ist auch
der schafft das niemals der Schaft nicht
mal aufgestellt zu werden dann ist er
Kandidat geworden in dieses Jahr das
schafft er auch niemals und er hat's
geschafft also unmöglich ist es sicher
nicht aber ich glaube es wird schon
schwierig für ihn ja nicht die Europäer
entscheiden sondern der Amerikaner und
was wir nicht vergessen dürfen Trump ist
nicht aus eigenem Leistung Präsident
geworden sondern aus Gegenreaktion auf
die linke und auf die Demokraten und
wenn sie so weitermachen dann hat Trump
eine Chance was sich nicht hoffe aber
das ist nicht nur das was Trump
veranstaltet sondern was die Demokraten
im Alltag und wie fremd ihre Politik
gegenüber die Mehrheit der Amerikaner
geworden ist das macht mir Sorgen
das Ergebnis jetzt darf er nicht so
spricht also normalerweise kriegt ein
ein amerikanischer
präsidents abwarten ich sage noch mal
das ist nicht die Europäer die
entscheiden auch nicht unsere Kanzler
aber trotzdem glaube ich dass die
Unzufriedenheit unter die Amerikaner und
wir wissen nicht wie wie eine Inflation
auch weitergeht das konnte auch für eine
Demokratie noch gefährlich das ist nicht
wir entscheiden aber natürlich haben wir
also über beobachten ja die Politik und
gerade bei so einem Land ist so relevant
ist einmal für die globale Betrachtung
der Probleme wie die USA schauen
natürlich sehr genau hin das Problem von
Trump ist er polarisiert halt wirklich
wie kaum ein anderer Politiker in der
demokratischen Welt und da gibt es
zunehmend meiner Wahrnehmung nach
amerikanische Werte die dieses extreme
polarisieren abstößt die einfach
tatsächlich auch wieder Ruhe wollen
Probleme lösen angehen und ja der Traum
der Politiker der wirklich der Menschen
Ruhe geben Probleme lösen die Menschen
dass sie nicht auf Polarisierung stehen
das kann man so eigentlich nicht sagen
oder auf ehrliche Worte kann man es auch
nennen
also ehrliche Worte werden geschätzt
dabei ein Haken dran und das ist eher
ein Problem der Politik dass wir zu viel
außen rum schwarfen aber das sind ja
nicht Polarisierung
Trump ist ja stark geworden weil er
Probleme die tatsächlich da sind
aufgenommen hat sehr polarisierend
gemacht und hat sich überspitzt und hat
noch mal an obendrauf gesetzt dann noch
ein bisschen Verschwörung mit
reingarniert das hat ihn ja stark
gemacht aber die Probleme die Menschen
wollen ja das Probleme gelöst werden ist
keiner suhlt sich ja gerne darin oh mann
wir haben 10 % Inflation bitte lasst es
uns die wollen die Lösung der Probleme
und das da ist Trump nicht stark eine
Sache die Trump ja von sich behauptet
ist ja er ist ja nie verlegen um große
Sprüche aber eine Sache die er behauptet
ist dass der Ukraine Krieg nicht mit ihm
angefangen hätte es werden wir am Tisch
jetzt nicht debattiert bekommen aber
bestimmt oder nicht stimmt aber sehen
Sie auch irgendeinen Vorteil den es
hätte wenn Donald Trump regieren würde
ja das ist schwer zu sagen
also Donald Trump ist erratisch das
macht natürlich für die Partner und ich
finde Deutschland muss ich sehr klar als
Partner als Freunde USA begreifen macht
für die Partner natürlich sehr schwierig
und das große Thema wie wie bekommen wir
die Welt irgendwie von der klimakrippe
runter wie schaffen wir den Klimawandel
zu beherrschen das wird ohne die USA
nicht gehen
ist dass ich da mal ganz kurz rein ich
finde das immer sehr spannend wie das
gesehen wird dass man Trump kritisiert
und dass da viel ja fragwürdig ist ist
klar aber er wurde er damals als ja
rückständig und die Globalisierung wird
zurückgedreht und Handelskrieg was die
Amerikaner jetzt nach Trump machen das
ist ja noch mal eine Stufe Schärfe also
man verkauft den Chinesen keine Chips
mehr man macht jetzt diesen Inflation
reduction Act der gegen die
Welthandelsorganisation gegen die
Statuten verstößt gut das hat sogar auch
habe ich schon mitbekommen dass das
vielleicht nicht ganz so gutes für
andere Länder also man macht er wirklich
härteste Industriepolitik wenn Trump das
macht dann heißt es ja oh der böse Trump
wenn beiden das macht habe ich das
Gefühl zumindest bei uns interessiert
eigentlich gar nicht jede Entscheidung
administration in der trumpzeit war
falsch aber
er hat ganz systematisch das
Zusammenspiel zwischen den Völkern
unterminiert und das ist ein natürlich
ein Problem weil wir werden keine schöne
Reden wir haben keine keine
Weltregierung am Ende des Tages wissen
wir das leider hinnehmen wenn immer die
Amerikaner wählen er ist aber als
Underdog als ausreiter als
protestfigur gestartet und das kann er
nicht mehr jetzt könnte er nach seiner
eigenen Darstellung
zur zum Establishment und ich also ich
glaube schon dass sie ihm nicht
vorstellen werden
Demokraten machen Trump starten ja klar
keine Politik der Mitte unsere Schwäche
hat Scholz stark gemacht ohne unsere
schwächer wäre weil sie nicht spielen
wollte
eine spd-2 wollten aber es ist eine
andere Sache bitte
aber dann machen wir doch zum Ende
meiner These mal eine Abstimmung und
schauen dann mal ob wir nah oder doch
Fernsehen sobald es dann dazu kommt wer
denkt denn das Donald Trump schafft die
Republikaner also nicht präsidents
werden aber für die Präsidentschaftswahl
antreten zu dürfen
ich sage nicht ich sage ja ja also eine
Stimme er wird die Präsidentschaft zwar
antreten dürfen nein nein und zwar
nachdem ich mit den republikörnern
geredet habe okay nach der Erfahrung in
Israel ja also im Gegensatz zu den
Demokraten haben die Republikaner ja
nachwuchskönner da sind ja tatsächlich
ein paar Talente wenn die den Mut haben
zu sagen ja bin bereit ich versuch's
dann glaube ich nicht dass das wird ja
auf jeden Fall gegen Kandidaten bekommen
also sagen sie nein also ich glaube
nicht dass Donald Trump der nächste
Präsident bei den Staaten
okay also nein ja ja nein ich bin ich
bin auch für nein bei Ivanka Trump fehlt
sonst wäre ich für ja gewesen aber ohne
Ivanka glaube ich wird das gar nichts
werden